nous allons voir ben oui c'était on a
été surpris par la brièveté de la
réponse je pense que les téléspectateurs
l'ont été aussi
comment est ce que vous êtes comment est
ce que vous expliquez ça j'ai eu la
trouille vous pensez que l a toujours
pas d'idée sur la question non mais là
elle a quasiment donné l'explication
avec presque une naïveté qu'on n'avait
pas l'habitude de voir chez elle en
disant à mes électeurs ne suivait pas
donc il fallait bien que je change sur
ce point le problème c'est que ce
programme économique ne tenait que dans
la perspective d'une sortie de l'euro et
de l'europe
c'est comme si vous enleviez la pierre
angulaire d'un édifice matou s'écoule
veux pas revenir à la retraite à 60 ans
et proposer le programme extrêmement
sociale qu'elle propose en restant dans
l'europe
donc elle est bien embêté j'ai bien aimé
l'expression de françois lenglet qui a
dit sur le plateau elle n'a pas réussi à
décroiser ses skis sur l'euro on a
vraiment cette impossible même